[Music]
here's your money briefing for Tuesday
April 11th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
[Music]
even as wallets get thinner most of us
have more than we need in our wallet boy
and adoyan from the Wall Street
journal's personal finance team joins me
to discuss what financial advisors say
you shouldn't leave home without Oyen
thanks so much for being with us thanks
for having me Jr so you know oyan
wallets these days they're almost like
accessories they come in all sorts of
colors and sizes yeah and they used to
be a lot bigger technology has been
shrinking while it's for centuries from
something more like a knapsack in
Shakespeare's day wait a knapsack yeah
okay so they're a familiar flat shape
after paper money became widespread and
again after credit cards came about in
the 1950s all right and you know for a
lot of people their wallet is a
microcosm of their financial life
they've got credit cards like you said
they've got their ID some cash maybe a
couple of store rewards cards so let's
start with credit cards how many credit
cards are too many according to people
you spoke with yeah according to
financial experts people should be
carrying three credit cards maximum and
one of the should be a debit card one of
those should also be from a different
company than maybe the other credit card
so for example if you have an American
Express credit card it might be good
that your other one is from Visa all
right so three credit cards one of those
should be a debit card but we live in a
digital world is even that number too
much you know is there anything that's
best to keep in your phone versus your
wallet yeah plastic is getting displaced
too 59 of Americans said that they
increased their use of digital payment
methods last year according to
mastercard's new payments index there's
so many things you can put on your
phones these days it turns out that the
implementation of Apple pay and Subway
terminals on buses and at grocery stores
has actually helped to increase the
number of people who actually put their
credit cards on their phones as opposed
to using the fiscal card all right so
let's talk about cash we probably know
just as many people who carry no cash as
we know people who carry some well the
pandemic also really played a big role
in this too for more than 10 Americans
say none of their purchases in a typical
week are paid for using cash according
to a 2022 survey from the Pew Research
Center and that's up from 29 in 2018 and
24 in 2015. so how much cash do experts
suggest people carried if at all well
listen to this so apparently people
carry an average of 67 in their wallets
that might be a little bit too much
though some Financial experts say
Chelsea Ransom Cooper for example who is
the director of financial planning at
Zenith Wealth Partners suggests that
people only need about 30 bucks
people need cash for maybe unexpected
moments like tipping but it can also be
something that people need to keep track
of in their day-to-day I spoke to this
professional poker player from New York
and he said A good rule of thumb for him
is to only ever carry a sum of cash in
your wallet that you're mentally
prepared to lose a poker player said
that so in case he stops by a poker game
to like tens now with the exception of
the poker player who carries thousands
sometimes you know for the rest of us
the cash we carry it's unlikely to cover
all the things that you might purchase
during a given day right yeah exactly
but that could actually work to some
people's advantage I spoke to a
marketing professor in Boston who
studies spending behavior and she says
that paying in cash can actually help to
curb overspending because the emotional
toll of spending bills is greater than
when you pay with your phone or a credit
card for example cuts down maybe on
impulsive buying yeah exactly because
it's physically painful to see Cash go
away but when you're paying with your
phone or when you're paying with a card
it doesn't really register as much but
some credit cards in cash you know that
can start to take up space What should
people be mindful of in terms of the
number of items in their wallet so I
learned that people who walk around with
too many things in their wallets are
actually at a greater risk of identity
theft because those are little things
that can help someone who might steal
your wallet to identify who you are and
get into your accounts and other
sensitive information A good rule of
thumb is to create a list of what's in
your wallet first and then from there
see if there's anything that can be
removed in order to reduce the risk of
identity fraud in the case of a lost or
stolen wallet now you mentioned identity
theft identity fraud before that's a
scary thought for anybody but it almost
Springs to light that having your ID in
your wallet is like a double-edged sword
because your idea is there but at the
same time is your ID and your wallet
enabling some sort of fraud it could but
most people can't get around without
having your ID with you and states are
slowly adopting the digital ID only
eight states allow their residents to
upload their driver's licenses or estate
ID cards to their apple wallet but if
you do lose your wallet you want someone
to still be able to return it to you
experts suggest slipping a small piece
of paper with your phone number on it in
there just so that they can contact you
alright that's the Wall Street journals
oyan adoyan with us oh yeah thanks for
being with us thanks thanks for having
me and that's your money briefing I'm
J.R Whalen for the Wall Street Journal
[Music]